una dura advertencia ante las
conversaciones estratégicas entre eeuu y
rusia
la unión europea y los estados miembros
tienen una posición de fuerza muy común
los eeuu están juntos los aliados de la
otan están juntos y estamos diciendo muy
claramente y estas son palabras muy
claras que habrán consecuencias masivas
y un coste severos y rusia se aventuran
ucrania con una acción militar una
muestra de unidad por parte de occidente
en su intento de disuadir a moscú de
invadir ucrania
el kremlin centro decenas de miles de
tropas rusas a lo largo de la frontera
ucraniana un movimiento de vladimir
putin mientras aumenta la presión sobre
occidente para detener la expansión de
la otan al este
putin lo puede aceptar que ucrania o
georgia se incorpore al otan o puede que
haya llegado a un acuerdo con los
estados bálticos que son una causa
perdida una parte de la otan y todo eso
decidió aferrarse al final en ucrania y
la única manera de asegurar su autoridad
política sobre ucrania es creando
tensión en la frontera
el domingo en las conversaciones de
ginebra rusia dijo que no se dejara
amenazar para hacer concesiones se trata
de una respuesta a las posibles medidas
punitivas que discute eeuu incluyendo
sanciones al círculo íntimo de putin la
cancelación del gasoducto ruso nord en 2
hacia alemania o la más drástica cortar
los vínculos de rusia con el sistema
bancario internacional
la casa blanca desestimó las exigencias
del kremlin sobre la otan como algo que
no tiene sentido tras el levantamiento
ucraniano de 2014 que derrocó un
gobierno cercano a moscú rusia ha
intervenido repetidamente en ucrania
anexionándose la península de crimea y
apoyando los levantamientos separatistas
en dos provincias del este